in every family there's one person who
drive you a little crazy
I got a pic Jill up at 4:00 in the
morning she comes once a year and she's
leaving on Sunday Jack and Jill stars
Adam Sandler Katie Holmes and Al Pacino
Wow more than likely you saw the
previews it's about a guy played by Adam
Sandler who has a sister who's a twin
who also was played by Adam Sandler and
she's going over for a vacation - Adam
Sandler's house and of course Sam was
very annoyed by her because she is very
annoying and boy is she annoying now a
lot of people were hating on this movie
because of the trailer and obviously
because of the premise and and you know
Adam Sandler and the female clothes and
everything and I was the one guy saying
you know what I love Adam Sandler it
could be good who knows dear God how are
we doing your twin sister
are you coming bald huh no no you're
getting fat in your hair doesn't realize
it needs to cover more faith okay this
is a terrible movie and I feel bad
saying it because I like Adam Sandler
Adam Sandler's seems like a really nice
guy from what I've heard of people
who've met him he is a really nice guy
and I like him a lot I think he's funny
but this is not one of his brighter
moments unfortunately you know it's
funny the look Adam Sandler has on the
poster of this movie is kind of how I
felt watching this movie it's like this
from the producers of just go with it
and grownups
thank you I so like we got nothing alike
I'm a shield crowd a large portion of
this movie I had like this expression on
my face and I was kind of awkward all of
a sudden sitting next to some of these
people I had this expression on my face
it was just kind of like I love Adam
Sandler I love the guy I think he's
funny I think some of his movies are
funny but this is not one of them Jill
this is Otto nice to meet you nice to
meet you no that's right are you
whispering with a bullhorn or something
everybody hear you one of my biggest
issues with this film is it's rated PG
which is odd because you know it's just
weird but the reason I have a problem
with that is because the film has no
idea what its demographic is there's a
lot of racist jokes in the movie for a
PG rated film there's a lot of jokes
that the kids are gonna go to and
they're not gonna understand which is
weird but honestly the biggest problem
half of the film is Adam Sandler's
character of Jill she's not funny at all
she's incredibly annoying and I know
that she's supposed to be annoying her
character is supposed to be annoying but
she should also be funny which is not
very present the film I couldn't live
together things I want to do before I
leave studio tour Beach horseback riding
oh my god maybe I should stay out
through Hanukkah the voice is pretty
annoying you're looking fat what's wrong
with you look a little chubby there in
the waist oh my gosh it's like that for
the whole movie
Al Pacino was in this movie weird
there's actually a scene at the end that
the audience was really cracking up a
queer al Qaeda sees like some footage of
something that he was involved with and
he's like burned every copy dollar does
never see the public light I was like
that's hilarious cuz that's kind of how
this movie is for his career
compliments of mr. Pacino why
this is insane man you got a call oh oh
we can stop reading you know all you
want to do is play twister with the
assistant Katie Holmes is actually
pretty hot in this movie if I do say so
myself
every time Katie Holmes was on screen in
this movie I was like dang she's
actually pretty hot she looks good in
this movie I ain't gonna lie I'm not
going to rant about the film because I
wasn't expecting it to be great I mean
who would really be surprised watching
this movie I'm gonna get Jack and Jill
Addie and Xander is your sister and I
grew up on the same street when I look
at her I see me when I look at her I see
me to it if you liked this review you
can subscribe to my channel and get
stuck my eyes